yeah hello and welcome to this video I'm
playing tactical xia zhou ton Madhvi
mint VG McCleary met vision probably
probably somewhat somewhat correct ok so
let's see what we'll get i play them
quite often not sure how place the head
shocked my platy five yeah dunno nope it
is my standard line against a shock it's
one of those save lines that however if
black does not play it right you get a
very nice pollution so kind of curious
[Music]
if 495 20 of 393 i would like to go a
form but 95 looks a little bit a little
bit annoying yeah but Bishop e3 aside
really initio will seem
I'm going to close the door quickly the
sounds from the washing machine that's
quite irritating yeah this is what white
is aiming for like a hawk t1 and then
g45 always dangerous I thank you for
black
yeah but I don't think this is so great
93 will come 94 on the agenda we'll see
I mean black has some ideas d5 and b5
but unsure if they work in b5 quick beer
could be a move so I I'm not sure if I
should have played 92 so quickly you can
you can go to an ending I don't mind
that at all what is just better in
unending check
yeah let's all play too quickly i mean i
am better yam but let's not rush things
94 xe6 is just about saving it yeah
maybe I can prepare this a little bit
better look at this in 1090 form so 94
why isn't that winning stuff it's got 98
okay
maybe this one actually is interesting
98a for just totally shutting everything
down but then 95 might come home yeah
[Music]
ignite that it wasn't so great probably
the other one was better
yeah I think you're just taking us is
fine the structure that is is pretty
good pretty good for me black is
extremely passive it's normally the
right decision to take it but not
totally sure I can also start with this
yeah starting with this is also fine
thanks bishop he is really not doing all
that much my bishop looks fine but night
against bishop is pretty nice and to get
this can also take take on g7 player 5
this is also interesting
you
also play a form for e 5 and 94 is also
good
if night here it's nice but it's tough
to determine what's best
okay I'm going with with this I'm not
sure it's pretty clear that why should
have some roots to a good advantage but
it's hard to say what's best here I'm
simultaneously threatening f6 and 92 F
for
yeah until night f4 was my plan even
though you can argue ig3 could be
something but okay that can cannot be
bad it can be bad but will be I think
surprising if it was so 95 you just
steps back check you so maybe take it
and then grab f5 like that
you cannot take it out that should be a
deadly self pin if what you want is made
some and this is made regurge five mate
I think checkmate yeah yeah that line I
don't know if I've got fantastic score
with that and it's not easy for black to
play and don't ok let's see how this is
how this turned out so yeah yeah 495 I
failed was interested in here because I
want to play this jeff three and he i am
but this is what i thought i thought
this should be good but i wasn't sure
because it looks kind of loose yeah my
my my pieces here look loose but the
engine doesn't find anything
particularly great d 5 with the quality
[Music]
now possible that what's the most
principled way to play definitely after
this I'm getting I'm getting what I want
especially this i have worked d 1 and
now everything is nicely protected yeah
that's not easy to play i'm gaining
space and black not quite clear what
black is doing the engine wants to go h6
yeah i think probably just push h4 h5
mmm interesting but I can take her maybe
then aged 6
it must be somewhat better for white
yeah the idea is simply to play 93 or 94
checking d6 and here can maybe taking
his better check it should be a little
bit a little bit of an advantage anyway
yeah exactly if he takes double the
h-bond will take and then it's pretty
close to two dangerous tactics already
the long diagonal he is very strong so
he went back ok the engine just wants to
play this I wasn't sure Luke c6 and and
then rocked it you okay yeah certainly
f5 is the computers point yeah but what
should always again be better you have
got more space and so on c6 yeah this
was cannula I don't know what to do move
originally had planned this but I felt a
d5 isn't impossible oh why didn't I do
this then but sure yeah this is a very
nice structure Black has problems he
cannot easily play 5 a-4 as this always
gives me good square stem and why it has
a number of plans available the one that
the computer suggests play you for is
what I did taking away some squares but
from here it's not so clear what I
should do because many things are
certainly advantageous for me I
ultimately decided on this which is kind
of counterintuitive but it's you have to
progress make progress somehow
and this is I think one definite way to
do it but there are certainly other
options I also thought about some e 5
plan yeah now f5 is also given by the
comm so I didn't do didn't do too badly
this is this and it looks it looks
pretty awful 93 yeah this I thought
about that but I felt King g6 and I
didn't quite know what to do then I
looked you five here okay and I didn't
see that one but this is that also
better for wider this young it is
somewhat better you just six check
cheeks and this yeah I'm winning
building material yet here it's almost
impossible for him to us to stop the
maze now checkmate yeah pretty clean
game I think if anything he had
something in the opening 925 earlier but
after that I think it was pretty pretty
okay yeah okay thanks for watching